à la croisée du reggae et de l'électro
c'est là que l'on pourrait situer la
musique de sunrise oz le groupe formé en
2015 pioche dans les différents styles
pour créer sa propre identité faite
gorilla c'est un peu un groupe qui nous
influence dans le sens où il mélange
paille beaucoup de textures et ben voila
nous on est un peu dans cette démarche
quoi donc nos influences sont
large c'est un reggae puis ouvert sur
d'autres styles en essayant d'être dans
l'air du temps
et puis vu qu'on utilise des samples
donc forcément ça donne une texture plus
électronique
fort d'un premier album sorti en 2016 le
quintette a enchaîné les concerts la
tournée colorstore 2017 prévoit une
trentaine de dates dans toute la france
en résidence à la batterie de guyancourt
les musiciens travaillent aussi leurs
visuels on aime bien jouer sur les
contrastes
donc ça peut être des choses coloré
chaude avec au contraire des ambiances
un petit peu plus froide plus dark
l'idée c'est un petit peu l'image de
notre musique
à voir par exemple une rythmique reggae
donc qui soleil un petit peu alliée à
des sonorités plus électroniques donc
plus numérique beaucoup plus froides le
but du jeu avec les lumières c'est
vraiment de servir la musique pour
pouvoir mettre le public vraiment dans
une ambiance et englober tout le monde
quoi ce que ça peut se faire à l'oreille
mais aussi en visuel de se sentir un
petit peu dans une bulle ça ça aide à
rentrer dans l'univers
le public pourra découvrir ce savant
mélange sur scène vendredi 3 février en
première partie de pablo moses un
concert qui marque le début de la
tournée jusqu en août
son temps
[Musique]